I'm the same way.
Oh, you're a paranoid schizophrenic, too.
I'm not schizophrenic.
Welcome back, everyone. It's Charlie.
This will be my fall
Last of us Episode three Video.
There were a whole bunch of Easter eggs
and references to the game,
so we'll break it all down.
It's probably going to go down
as one of the best episodes of the series
and probably one of the best episodes
of television just period this year.
If you're brand new to the channel
and doing videos for all the episodes,
be sure to subscribe to get them all.
We're doing a giveaway
for HBO Max subscriptions.
All you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber
and just post your favorite moment
from the episode on the video.
Carefully respond to the episode
if you haven't seen it yet.
We'll go through shot by shot,
talking about Easter eggs and WTF moments,
starting with the episode title
Long Long Time, a reference to the Linda
Ronstadt song that
Frank and Bill played for each other,
which is all about surviving in general.
Being alone. Human relationships.
Being in love,
which was a big theme of the episode
and just of the Last of US
series in general,
trying to survive, allowing yourself
to be open to human relationships,
creating close bonds with each other.
The opening
scene of the episode is of Joel and Ellie
right after the events of Episode two,
with Joel soothing his wounded hand nearby
in a stream and constructing
a pyramid out of rocks from the stream.
The rock tower he's building
is just meant to be a memorial to Tess,
like his way of eulogizing her,
remembering her because he's trying
to push past all these negative emotions,
all this sadness inside him.
That's the big thing with his character.
Like he doesn't want to have anything
to do with dealing with his feelings.
There'll be no therapy in this episode
or future episodes any time soon.
That's one of the big differences
with Ellie's character,
is that she wants to open up.
She wants to talk about
all of these really hard
things, these traumatic things
that happen to them.
But Joel doesn't want to deal
with any of that stuff right now.
At least he's going to tamp down
on all those terrible negative feelings
inside me and continue on.
He's just about sheer survival right
now, like he's in pure survival mode,
going to tamp down all those terrible
negative emotions inside me.
The part that they cut from the game
here is at the end of episode two,
they have to continue escaping
the rest of the way out of Boston.
In the game,
they use the abandoned subway terminals
until they get to the woods
outside of Lincoln,
which is where they're headed
to where Bill lives.
The fact that Joel gave her his jacket
here to stay warm is also meant to be
a sign that he's slowly
treating her in a more caring way,
like he's
being a little bit more thoughtful,
even though he's still trying
to push her away.
As you see at the end of the episode, it's
not because he totally hates Ellie
or he blames her for Tess's death
or anything like that.
It's just that he's afraid to get close
to other people because ultimately
he feels like he's going to lose them
and will just make him feel even worse.
He doesn't want to hit rock bottom
emotionally again,
like he actually genuinely
cared about Tess,
and it hurt badly to lose her
after losing his daughter.
So he doesn't want to go
through the pain of that again.
And that's why he doesn't want
to get close to Ellie, at least right now.
But it all goes back to the
theme of the episode that Linda
Ronstadt song and the whole idea of Bill's
arc in the series
and how he got close to Frank
and how it ultimately fulfilled him.
He was happy to go out the way that he did
because Frank had enriched his life
so much.
So a lot of Bill's
storyline in the episode,
especially the message that he leaves for
him, is meant to inspire Joel
to get closer to Ellie.
Ultimately,
it'll be worth it for better and worse.
It's about a lot of these
early parts of the series.
You see Ellie's influence on him,
like she's relentlessly positive
in the face of all this terrible stuff
that's happening to them.
Just a lot of her
enjoying things in the moment.
A lot of the first that she has,
like seeing the forest for the first time,
like she's never been camping,
never been outside the quarantine zones,
she's never been in a car before.
So the whole idea
is that you see little moments like this
throughout the episode,
throughout the series,
the first couple of episodes
where Joel slowly starts to act
a little bit more like a dad with her.
If you zoom in enhanced on her backpack
here, too,
you notice that she has her monster
keychain from the games.
Little Easter Egg.
I don't think that Neil Druckmann
has ever explained
where the actual monster
keychain came from or what inspired it.
It looks like it's either based on Pixar's
Monsters Inc, like Microsoft's Psyche
or the Ugly Dolls line of toys.
We might learn how she actually got it
in the flashbacks in her origin story
when they tell those in future episodes.
The reason
why she doesn't have the backpack
from the games yet
like this is a slightly different backpack
is because she doesn't get that one
until much later in the first game.
So we might also see her
get that backpack in a future episode
because for the most part,
like the clothes that she's wearing,
the clothes that Joel is wearing,
pretty much everybody else, for
the most part, are right out of the game.
They're meant to be fairly accurate
costumes.
Later in the episode, Ellie
also gets another one of her video game.
T shirts.
Even during episode two.
The lighter that Tess used to sacrifice
herself is right out of the games.
Neil Druckmann said that the costume
department in the props department
paid special attention to that.
They were always asked how to make things
look more like they did in the game.
A lot of their dialog here
is also taken directly out of the game.
Only rabbit in the woods.
What?
Nothing. That's just.
I've never seen anything like this.
That's all you need in the woods?
Yeah. Never walked in the woods.
It's kind of cool.
The reason why Joel is taking them to
Bill's is because he thinks
that they can get a car there
that will take them the rest of the way
to Wyoming, to Jonesboro, either
because of the timing of the episode
when a bunch of the big events
wind up happening.
At this point,
when he's taking them there,
he still thinks that Bill and Frank
are still alive.
The way they timed this,
the way the countdown works on the radio,
the warning message that goes off,
it sounds like they died
right before the events of episode one.
But as they start
hiking the rest of the way,
Joel starts to explain to her
that the real danger here isn't so much
the infected, it's
actually the Raiders, the real people.
And that's a big thing
throughout the entire Last of US
series through the games.
The idea that people are just as bad
as the fungus, we will continue
to meet very terrible, very bad people
as we go along through the series.
In fact, Troy Baker, who did the voice of
Joel in the games, is actually
playing one of the antagonistic characters
later in the series.
No spoilers
about what's going on with their group
because we will see them
in a future episode.
But this is Troy Baker from the Games
they also use a lot of Bill and Frank's
flashbacks to show you that sometimes
humans can be just as bad as the infected.
Like when Ellie finds the bodies
next to the downed airplane,
he explains that all the people
were killed by the military
not because they were infected,
but because they didn't have room for them
in the quarantine zones.
And it was very much shoot first,
ask questions later,
which is another reference to the
death of his daughter, like she died
even though she wasn't infected.
Bill makes a lot of references
to the government during the episode too.
Like you shouldn't trust the government.
They're all terrible.
Turns out he was right.
Joel starts referencing people and things
that they'll reveal in future flashbacks,
like how he got the scar, who Frank is
when they're looking for supplies
in the convenience store
that Joel keeps stash.
Ellie finds the Mortal Kombat
two arcade machine.
It's a reference to an in-game Easter egg
for Mortal Kombat.
Two had a poster of it on her bed
at the beginning of the game.
The friend
she mentions who was really into
it is Riley, who she's referenced
a couple of times in the series
so far, played by Storm Reed.
We'll see her in future flashbacks.
All of her story
takes place before Ellie met Joel,
so it'll all be dealt with in flashbacks.
While she's exploring the story,
she finds the trapped remains of either
the former owner or a fellow survivor
who had been infected and trapped there
while the ceiling had collapsed.
He's meant to be in the Shamblers state,
which is what they turn into
a little while
after the initial stage,
which are runners.
The collapse seemed like
it happened a long time ago, but
maybe he just didn't turn fast enough
because the body couldn't find enough fuel
that the fungus didn't have enough fuel
to evolve him into the next day.
This whole scene is about her
taking her anger out on it, showing
that she's not afraid,
mostly to reassure herself,
but also as a cathartic way to deal with
all the really messed up stuff
that's happened to her
in all the even more messed up stuff
that happened in the flashbacks
that we haven't seen yet.
So it's less of her trying to do something
good, putting it out of its misery
than it was about her finding catharsis
through it.
Also to show you that
she's not quite as helpless as she seems,
which also dovetails
with the idea that she keeps asking Joel
for a gun throughout the episode
until she finally finds Bill's gun
at the end of the episode.
That'll probably come in handy
pretty soon.
The crash plane isn't meant to be
the same one from episode one,
because that was happening
way down in Austin.
But it is a callback to that.
The whole idea is Joel's explaining
what happened is that during the chaos,
people started turning
while these planes were mid-air, causing
most of them to crash all over the world.
Joel, saying that
he knows how to fly is another reference
to his history in the military.
They also have an Easter egg for Sully's
plane from Uncharted in the Last of US
games because Naughty Dog,
who make the Last of US
games, also made the Uncharted games.
Joel explains the origin of the cordyceps
fungus to Ellie,
which we saw during the flashbacks
in episode two.
And his explanation,
which he's just making an educated
guess about, is totally correct.
The cordyceps was a common fungus
that mutated and infected
the flower made in the world's
largest flower factory in Jakarta.
It was distributed all over the world,
winding up in people's food products,
Even though there was that
one person that the military lost
track of, like, well,
we don't know where
that one person went to.
And they theoretically went around biting
people and the fungus spread that way.
It spread across the world
even faster because of the flour.
The big takeaway
here is the switch to eating more rice
instead of so much bread
and flour products.
This episode, sponsored
by Rice, also confirms
the pancake flour theory from episode one.
The reason why he, his brother
and his daughter didn't turn like
everyone else
is because they were out of pancake flour
that day,
whereas their neighbors had the biscuits,
the cookies.
He goes on to recall
everything that happened
that night in 2003
that we saw part of during episode one.
At this point, he's
not speculating anymore because he's
speaking from experience like he's
recounting things as they happened to him.
And even though we're still kind of
dealing with a global pandemic
in real life right now, everything
that's happening in the episode
isn't meant to be a reference to that,
even if it feels like it.
All the stuff with the fungus spreading
and all that craziness was written
more than ten years ago.
It is a very dark coincidence
that we're going through something similar
in real life right now.
Also, in the games, the present day
is meant to be 2033, not 2023.
After Ellie learns about all the extra
terrible things that Federer did,
killing all the regular people in addition
to the infected, they pin it on the dead
bodies of the mother and her baby,
flashing back to September 30th, 2003,
to show you Bill's origin story in Franks
and this entire part of the episode, all
these flashbacks are not from the game.
This is a big change,
but I actually think it's
a really good change in it actually bodes
well for future seasons.
Like a lot of people have problems
with The Last of US too.
Video game story.
This means when they eventually adapt
that stuff in future seasons,
they can change it for the better.
The whole idea in the video games
is they find a version of Bill,
but it's like a much darker version
of the character long after
Frank has died
and is driven him to a very dark place.
It's a much more depressing
take on this whole encounter
that they have in the episode,
in the message
that Bill gives them in the TV
version of the episode.
In the game, Bill was meant to be a darker
mirror for what could
potentially happen to Joel
if he continued to push people away.
But they show you
how Bill was a survivalist,
and that's part of the reason
why he was able
to survive
the initial outbreak of the fungus,
because his house was essentially
constructed like a fortress.
He'd already
all kinds of defensive measures, set up
all kinds of weapons, like his gear,
his whole shelter here created
long before the fungus actually happened.
He taunts the military, showing you
how deeply he mistrusted them.
When they're looking
for all the people in the town.
It turns out pretty smart move on his part
because that whole group that they
just drove off with in the military trucks
were taken to the field to be killed.
Notice
that he's wearing a gas mask in the game.
The fungus
give off spores that can infect you
even after you've killed one of them.
So the characters frequently
have to run around everywhere
wearing gas masks,
especially when they're going to new areas
In the first time in the game that you
see, Bill, he's wearing this mask.
The reason they cut the spores
out of the show
is because they didn't want to have
everyone's faces covered all the time.
Even though
Pedro Pascal also plays The Mandalorian
and he covers his face all the time.
It's one of the major
concedes of the character.
The spray paint on
the front of his door
is from the military,
just a mark that his house
had been checked for people.
And that's where the data on here says.
934 September 30th.
You can see later after the flash forwards
that they eventually painted over, that
you notice that his first act was to raid
the same gas station
that Joel just visited with Ellie,
where he'd stashed all of his stuff,
taking as many supplies
as he can find gas, food, anything of use.
He was ready to go for this
like he was prepared.
The reason he goes to the utility
station is to turn
the gas back on to his house
because one of the military's first acts
would have been
to shut all that stuff down.
He uses a generator for regular power,
but he still needs the gas
from the normal utility station.
The car that he's using to grab
all the supplies is also the same car
that he winds up giving to Joel and Ellie
later in the episode
to get the rest of the way to Wyoming.
Love the montage of him
finishing his preparations, too.
He creates more traps
all around the house,
sets up a small farm gardens for his food,
make sure that the area
is self-sufficient for years of this
go by in the finds, Frank
just a normal human who had stumbled
into one of his traps after fleeing
the Baltimore quarantine zone
after it had fallen to the fungus.
When Frank is talking about it,
he says it's gone.
He means that the fungus, the infected,
essentially destroyed the quarantine zone.
There is no more quarantine
zone in Baltimore.
The other nine people that he was
traveling with had died along the way.
At some point on the way to the Boston
quarantine zone.
You know, love their whole first meeting
here.
Like, is this hilarious?
Just him trying to figure out
what's going on with Bill and Bill,
trying to deal with another human.
I wonder if Arby's paid them
for this product placement here.
Arby's has to be one of the most clowned
upon food franchises in TV shows.
Bill shows him some compassion and cooks
the meal for him.
Loved that.
He has no idea what to do
with all the franks compliments
to his kindness.
The tales of Hoffman music
is also a reference
to Bill and Frank story together.
It was a French opera, and in the story
the protagonist is thematically similar
to Bill.
Then they whip out the Linda Ronstadt song
Long, Long Time, which is where
the episode gets its title from,
and they use the lyrics of the song
as a metaphor for Bill
and Frank's story, their relationship
as well as Joanne Lees story.
It's all about surviving,
taking things in stride,
buying it
all, falling in love with someone,
allowing yourself
to care about someone else.
In this, basically what these two couples
are doing slowly over
time, obviously, Bill
and Frank a little bit quicker.
Also love the joke about him
telling Bill to go take a shower
like this is all great love
what's going on here.
But you stink.
Literally. You have not taken a shower
in a long time.
Go clean yourself.
And they confirm a lot of people's
suspicions after the game
because the game didn't
have any of this stuff during the game.
When you meet Bill, Frank is already dead.
He'd killed himself
and Bill talks about him finally implying
that they had a relationship together.
They flash forward
three more years to 2010
and they show you how Frank started
working with more outsiders
like Joe and tests.
As Frank started to go crazy
from all the bill's isolationist paranoid
tactics in as Frank says,
making more friends.
And it sounds like Frank definitely
felt like they were his friends.
But at the end of the episode, Bill
kind of relies and says, You know what?
I wouldn't call you exactly a friend,
but you were kind of like a friend.
I respect you,
and that it was meant to be like
the highest form of compliment
that you get from someone like Bill.
You notice
when they're having dinner in the yard
for the first time,
Bill has the gun on them the entire time.
Joel verbally references
how similar they are
and their personalities,
the paranoid personalities.
Bill's line here about not needing
Joel and Tess complicating
his life is important for the future
of the series. It's what it's all about.
The idea that you're supposed to develop
those close bonds with other people,
allow them to complicate your lives
for better and worse.
That's the whole point of being alive.
Angell reluctantly wins him over
with the promise of enough material
to replace his fences
for the rest of his life,
appealing
to the survivalist instincts in him.
Very smart thinking on Joel's part
as they're leaving.
Frank also references the radio codes
that Joel told Ellie about in Episode one
so they could communicate with each other
in secret, where the songs came from,
the trouble that Frank also mentions here
is foreshadowing to the trouble
that they have with radio soon after this,
which Joel also talks to Bill about.
Like there's going to be Raiders
pretty soon,
as well as the trouble
at the end of the episode with the radio
goes off, they flash forward again
three more years to 2013.
Love his reaction when he finds out
that Frank traded away one of his guns.
Which one? As if it's one of his children.
Like you've given away one of my children.
That's how precious his guns are to him.
And then a very short while later, raiders
do come to steal their stuff,
setting off Bill's traps.
He's already
firing on them, hit in the crossfire.
And when Frank is trying to treat
his wound, he thinks he's going to die.
So he starts telling Frank
all the important things
he can think of, like how to survive
without him.
Called Joel.
Don't live alone. Here's
where the keys are.
But later in the episode,
they confirmed that
all the stuff that you see,
the flash forwards were real.
They actually did happen, meaning
that Frank really did save Bill's life
and they continue to grow old together.
They made some big changes from the video
game storyline in their back story,
but it's similar to
some things that happened in the game.
In the backstory of the video game, Frank
got infected and killed himself
before the infection could take him.
Bill wound up surviving and just drove
into a very dark place on the show.
Frank basically does the same thing.
Only instead of the fungus that took him,
it was a neurological condition
that was killing him, and he chose to end
his life before it got worse.
And Bill also chose to end his life with
him, even though it's still super dark.
It's a much more positive
spin on the characters than in the game.
Like the whole episode
just felt way more positive,
even though there's
a lot of really dark stuff that happens.
That's why I say there's a lot of hope
when we get to season two,
Season three, like future seasons
of the Making It Even Better version
of The Last of US two storyline.
Bill talking to Frank
about how he lives a happy
life, he's been fulfilled
through his relationship with Frank
is meant to be foreshadowing
for Jill and Le's future father daughter
relationship like Joel will go through
a similar character arc in the future.
When they're panning around the house,
they show
you Frank's artwork
that he did over the years.
This one's a bill in the chair.
This one's a bill's face.
I think this other one is supposed to be
of Joel, though,
because it's of a younger person.
This is also meant to be the last
one of bill that you see in present day.
Kind of confirming the timeline.
Frank's condition has made it hard for him
to get around, hard for him to do
basic tasks, which is why he comes
to the decision to end his life.
And he creates this elaborate swansong
ending for himself to have one last
good day with Bill, then euthanize himself
before the disease can get even worse.
And as they carry their plan out,
they paint around
all the locations
that were important to their history.
Like the trap
where he met Bill for the first time,
the garden that Frank surprised him
with ten years ago.
They get married,
they have the special dinner.
And if you couldn't tell the food
that Bill cooked him is meant to be
the exact same meal that he cooked for him
the first day that they met.
That's why Frank was so surprised
and happy about it.
Like, Oh, it's the same meal
that you made me that first time.
The first wine that they drink
is also meant to be the same.
Why they drink on that day.
The second bottle of wine is
the one that was spiked with the medicine.
And if it wasn't clear from the reaction
on Frank's face,
they kind of talk about it
a little bit more after the fact.
But when Bill downed his wine in one gulp,
he had spiked
the entire wine bottle before he poured
both glasses.
That's why when Frank asked
if his was enough to take care of the job,
Bill said that
that would be enough to kill a horse
because he'd already
given him a dose of it in the bottle.
But the whole idea here is that Frank
says that he lived a life of purpose.
He's completely fulfilled.
Frank was his purpose, so he doesn't want
to continue living without him.
When Joel and Ellie arrive,
you see the final painting of Bill
that Frank had been doing
just before they died.
The wine bottles on the table, the food
this only slightly decomposed, just lets
you know how recently they died.
It seems like
it's only been a couple of days
because it's only been a couple of days
since episode
one confirming that they died
right before the events of episode
one, just because of
when the countdown in the bunker went off.
Ellie finds the letter that Bill left
for Joel and tests because remember, Bill
didn't know the test died on the way out.
And also Joel didn't know
that Bill and Frank had died either.
And here's one of the other big changes
from the video game.
So the message that Ellie reads
is almost the exact opposite
of what Bill tells Joel
at the end of their scenes in the game,
The letter talks about how he was wrong
to push everyone away his whole life.
There's always that one person out there
worth saving.
And for him it was frank
and it's meant to inspire Joel.
The Ellie is going to become that person.
But obviously, as happy as the episode
was, this ending was for them.
They found everything that they needed.
They also want to remind you how grim
and traumatic things are by referencing
Tess in the letter,
just reminding Joel why it is
that he pushes so many people away.
One of the other differences
here, too, is that when they arrive
at Bill's in the game,
a lot of that part of the game
is them going on missions
to try and assemble the parts that they
need to actually get the car to start.
Whereas during the episode, Bill
basically just gives them the car in.
The battery is almost ready to go.
They also look at the blue
order encounter,
which Ellie referenced in episode two.
The infected with extra tough hides
the true spore bombs.
Maybe we'll see more blotters in future
episodes.
The reason Joel smiles when he opens
the fridge is because he finds the car
battery pretty much ready to go.
I at the charge a little bit, which they
also kind of have to do in the game too.
They have to charge the battery
by getting the car to run.
And he's also smiling,
looking at the battery
because it's a reference back to episode
one is the reason why he wound up mixed up
with Ellie in the first place
over the stolen car battery.
They make their plan to go out to Wyoming
to Tommy's settlement, to check on him
and then see if he can help them
get Ellie to the other fireflies,
which is also right out of the game.
They head there during the game,
and we've seen footage of them
in the trailers
to Ellie's whole conversation to Joel
about trying to talk about her goes
exactly how it did in the game.
Like this is all a dialog
taken right out of the game.
Listen about test rule one.
You don't bring up tests ever, but test.
I don't even know.
Here's how this thing's going to play out.
You don't bring up tests ever.
The whole idea is that Joel
just hits the pause
button on working through his feelings.
Like,
we will not be dealing with anything.
There's
no therapy going on in this episode.
Who's that sadness deep down inside you
when they go down to the bunker?
The song that's playing
is The Racers Chains of Love,
which is a reference to the song
that was playing over the radio
in episode one,
the sign that there was trouble coming.
And Joel confirms
the timeline, explaining that
that countdown was set to play this
in case he didn't reset it.
Every day.
Me that Bill and Frank died
just before the events of episode one.
The Bugs
the women shirts that they find is
where Ellie gets her T-shirt,
which is also right out of the games.
I think in this context,
they're meant to have gotten
this box of women shirts,
even though there are no women
that lived here
from scavenging around the town.
Ellie finds Bill's handgun
finally getting a gun
that she'd been asking
for this whole time.
I think this is meant to be
the one that he always carried on his hip.
Pretty safe to assume
that gun is going to come in handy
eventually when they take off.
Joel, getting the seatbelt for her is him
also being kind of like a dad.
A lot of dad energy from Joel at the end
of the episode, going on a road trip.
Got to play a mix tape.
She finds the mix tape
that Frank made for Bill in the song.
Playing on it is the Linda Ronstadt song
like that was meant to be Bill
and Frank's song.
That's why he put it on the mix
tape. Like, This is our special song.
The window that the camera ends on
is the bedroom window where they died,
because he said in the letter
that he left the window
open to keep the house from sticking up.
And like I said,
as they played the song over
the end of the episode,
as they drive away,
the lyrics of the song are also meant
to be a metaphor
for the future of John Ellie's
relationship.
Finding someone else to care about
is probably going to go down
as one of the best episodes of the series.
Like I said, so it'll be interesting
to see if they can top this later
this season.
If you spotted any other Easter eggs
or references in the episode
that I didn't mention in the video
right down below in the comments,
my Episode four trailer video
we'll post next in my full episode
for video we'll post next Sunday
after they release it.
Congratulations, Midori Bushi,
You're the giveaway winner
from My Last Last of US video.
Please
email me on the about page of my channel
so I can get your contact details.
Everyone click here for the Last of US.
Episode four Trailer Video.
Update the link
as soon as I post the video and click here
for all my last of US episodes.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one.